these are unprecedented scenes in Hong
Kong a police force under attack and
facing raw fury from its fellow citizens
[Applause]
[Music]
the multiple tear gassing and hundreds
of rubber bullets fired the use of water
cannon and it's blue dye the aggressive
storming of subway trains as well as
apparently random and brutal arrests
have all led to huge anger against the
police for the first time we hear from
the police officers families about how
they're now pariahs in Hong Kong they're
so scared of revenge attacks
none of the four families we spoke to
wanted to be identified we are worried
emotionally stressed and not feeling
safe here in Hong Kong
she told us threats had been made
against her children it's torn her
extended family apart
with half of them not speaking to her I
don't have any fifty man I only have one
demand which is to keep my my kids safe
in a safe environment this is my only
demand which should be the right of
every parent but now it's not for us
October the first was a turning point
the first police shooting of a protester
[Applause]
it's sparked outrage protesters went on
a revenge rampage and please paid for it
with their blood these pictures we've
obtained show an officer who's been
sprayed with corrosive liquid have been
several policemen attacked like this the
police wives believe it's their men who
are paying for what our politicians
mistakes the Hong Kong government needs
to do something they need to start using
politics to govern the city rather than
using the Hong Kong police as a
political tool to help them most police
now wear masks themselves after their
identities were spread online and their
families hounded even when not working
they're not safe protestors say this
off-duty policeman ran into one of them
his car was quickly surrounded he got
out of his vehicle his right hand on his
holster and appeared to be trying to
calm the crowd when he was grabbed
around the neck from behind he holds his
hand up as if to fire in the air but the
crowd pulls him down
seconds later a shot is heard
and a 14-year old boy is hit in the leg
from another angle you see the crowd
setting on him beating him before a fire
bomb is thrown these acts terrified the
police families I'm worried about his
life and I'm burying that one day he
won't come back home I have two children
and they always asked where is my daddy
why can I see him every day but the
protesters are showing a real bitterness
towards the police it looked like you
were trying to hurt him maybe even kill
him yeah but he was kind of curious too
by firing do you think it's justified
that sort of behavior why because
they're trying to kill us with real
bullets it seems like war
I think it's war they're using the
emergency law this is the ugly reality
for Hong Kong's penis now it's tearing
communities and police families apart
making them think what had been
unthinkable before life divorce have you
actually thought of that yes and just
solely because two-port my kiss not
because of I don't love my husband
but I love my kiss war whilst the police
are out on the streets their spouses are
telling their children to keep their
jobs a family secret
but they're clearly filled with fear and
frustration I'm born in Hong Kong live
in Hong Kong more than 14 years we don't
know so much we care other one so much
but now I don't think so
I'm so disappointed about the Hong Kong
situation but right now sympathy is
scarce for the police or their families
and the gulf between police and
protesters is getting ever wider